here is one of the more interesting
buildings in San Francisco this is the
Department of Emergency Management at
10:11 Terk where I was graciously given
a tour this very morning so these slides
are very very fresh
they haven't faded yet um this is the
public safety dispatch and I was asked
not to you know show people's faces
there because people are conscious of
their privacy but there's a console for
each this is the police area which is
closest to the supervisors in case they
need coordination but AAA is the
Richmond District handheld a7 as the
well they call it that but a7 is on main
route dispatch for for cohosh richmond
para val and where's my brain anyway the
west side of the city so these are
incredibly sophisticated consoles and
this is what somebody sees a 911 call
taker and then a radio dispatcher this
is bogus you see it's made out to Fred
Flintstone it's a training screen
because we can't reveal any private
information but this was done this
morning and so all of this is typed in
and this rather sophisticated system
which is called a CAD computer assisted
dispatch keeps track of status and
assigns case numbers and so on it's
really really interesting but this is
part of the background they also see
maps and they see certain sensitive
locations are marked here so this is a
customized view a GIS view for Public
Safety dispatchers and they also do
triage if you make a medical call and
you complain that you think there's a
stroke these are questions that are
asked and then ultimately something has
put together for dispatch so that the
the first responders will know what to
do unlike some cities in San Francisco
medical dispatchers are not paramedics
they're civilians but this is a
medically developed system that helps to
triage ahead of time we have a really
complicated system inside a trunk system
in San Francisco it's getting old it's
analog it's no
longer was going to be supported and so
by 2018 there's a hope that they'll have
a fancy new digital system put in these
are all the police channels are used so
we don't use what's interesting is it's
a software thing now in the old days
fire used to have a channel police in
the north side had one channel police
and it's not done that way now it's all
done in software and so talk groups
which were sort of virtual paths that
are shared are set aside
[Music]